un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
sí no
[Música]
les damos la bienvenida a este carrusel
de las artes especiales desde la ciudad
de biarritz en el país vascofrancés
ciudad que celebra cada año el cine y
las culturas latinoamericanas en el
marco del festival biarritz américa
latina'
[Música]
30 largometrajes cortos y documentales
de 8 países compiten por los diferentes
premios del festival de biarritz y en
especial el premio el abrazo a la mejor
película de ficción en 2020 el festival
de biarritz pone el acento en los
latinos de eeuu a través de una
selección de nueve cintas que exploran
la realidad de la mayor minoría en suelo
estadounidense biarritz acoge al público
fiel del festival con drásticas medidas
sanitarias debido a la crisis del cob y
a las que muchos se pliegan con una
sonrisa
[Música]
la verdad
la ciudad de berriz se hace nuevamente
eco del cine y de las culturas
latinoamericanas en el marco del
festival biarritz américa latina un
festival que este año se desarrolla en
un contexto particular en virtud de la
epidemia del coronavirus que afecta a
francia sin embargo esta edición se
mantiene en 2020 y de esto vamos a
conversar ya mismo con el delegado
general del festival biarritz américa
latina
antoine serbia antón muchísimas gracias
por estar nuevamente en carrusel de las
artes un gusto estar en la causa y ahora
antoine a en virtud de este contexto
particular podríamos decir que es ya una
victoria poder hacer este festival en
2020 y ahora no creo que no se celebra
una victoria antes del final del
partido pero sí me siento muy afortunado
de estar acá sé que hubo muchos muchos
eventos que tuvieron que cancelarse y
fue un esfuerzo muy grande fue mucho
trabajo pero estamos muy felices de
estar hoy acá y hay algunos invitados
que no pudieron venir efectivamente los
directores o directoras que vienen de
américa latina la estatua y unos que
pudieron venir
pero las fronteras de la unión europea
estando cerradas con la mayor parte de
los países de latinoamérica tenemos una
delegación que no es tan importante de
lo que puede haber sido en los años
pasados y bueno hemos visto muchísimo
público en la ciudad de biarritz que
llenaron las salas de cine que llenaron
los espacios y es lo que vamos a ver
porque fuimos a el encuentro de estas
personas que vienen al festival de
biarritz
[Música]
yo no tengo miedo porque pienso que hay
que vivir y qué
qué hacer con este virus
[Música]
como da este año soy persona vulnerable
estamos en una época riesgosa por eso no
tome el abono semanal de distrito
llevaba 7 u 8 años viniendo antes
alquilar un apartamento para llegar a
primera hora y ver unas 5 películas al
día
para tranquilizar a los espectadores en
tiempos de comida el festival de
biarritz ha puesto en marcha un sistema
de reservaciones sophie weguelin es la
responsable del cine guay al
esto quiere decir que los abonados
pueden reservar en línea sus entradas
entonces tenemos vendedores de hasta el
50% de la capacidad de la sala los que
no lograron inscribirse pueden comprar
una entrada a 15 minutos antes de la
proyección visual con los miles 10.000
donaciones sin embargo la pandemia no ha
disuadido a los amantes del cine latino
y el inicio del festival la taquilla
llegó a su tope como lo explica
stephanie lugo coordinadora
administrativa del festival al final
tenemos la mitad de abonos que el año
pasado y estamos desde el fin de semana
pasado pero negando la venta de abonos
porque ya es suficiente para el aforo
que tiene que ser reducido este año
muchos espectadores son mayores y para
ellos la pasión del cine es más fuerte
que el miedo a la pandemia lo problema
es que este año hay menos menos
películas que están en competición es
por eso que haya menos menos gente que
tendrá fin y con la intención de ver
muchas películas y documentales es lo
que estoy haciendo y me gusta lo que
estoy viendo y además el ambiente y el
equipo de súper agradable su con las
precauciones que se ponen ahora está
siendo los sitios no no hay problema hay
que seguir a ver películas
[Música]
y seguimos en compañía aquí en carrusel
de las artes con antoine se viene el
delegado general del festival biarritz
américa latina aunque creo entender que
a pesar de la crisis recibieron
muchísimas películas de américa latina
para esta selección del 2020 y estas
tres competencias que se hacen todos los
años ex actor recibimos un poco menos
películas que los años pasados pero
vimos casi mil películas lo que es
muchísimo y pudimos mantener nuestras
competencias de cortometrajes de
largometrajes documentales y de ficción
de largos de ficción son muy muy felices
con eso
hoy en la que decir las cosas en la
pieza para que te lleve gracias sra
oye qué vueltas no va a haber ayunar por
navidad nos encantará pues hace siglos
que no funciona
[Música]
y ahora para el premio mayor de este
festival que es el premio el abrazo que
es el símbolo de la amistad entre
biarritz y américa latina nueve
películas de ficción háblanos un poco de
esa selección pues creo que lo que
cuando miramos respectivamente lo que
nos parece de esta selección es que
elegimos películas lúdicas
en las que los directores han tomado
mucho placer jugando con las
herramientas del cine y es lo que lo
bonito que que sobresale de esta
selección y hay una temática particular
este año creo que es eso es el juego es
explorar territorios nuevos y jugar con
el cine realmente son son películas que
se han hecho con mucho placer y con
mucha diversión se siente en la
programación muchísimas gracias o
antoine sevilla delegado general del
festival de biarritz nosotros vamos a
seguir explorando lo que es esta edición
2020 y justamente radio france
internacional y france 24 entregan el
premio al mejor documental de esta
selección nosotros fuimos al encuentro
de nadia solano quien es parte del
comité de selección de la categor
documentales sin radio
valverde / la competencia documental del
festival biarritz amérique latine es muy
importante es una sección que siempre ha
representado la gran producción de
américa latina en cuanto al documental
este año tenemos en competencia a 10
documentales bastante diferentes de
siete países latinoamericanos busca una
imagen que te hable de mí
es un cine de autor en el cual los
autores están explorando otras formas de
narrar las historias lo cual es muy
interesante y entre ellos el retrato es
algo que está caracterizando la
selección de este año
aquí me sentía seguro
el club no llegaban los gritos de las
protestas populares
mi mamá me decía que llegaría la
revolución con la evolución que hubo a
nivel de la cinematografía del
audiovisual que se democratizaron más
las herramientas para filmar
el documental fue mucho más accesible o
fue un paso que que de pronto llegó más
fácil en ese proceso en esa evolución
porque es una producción que necesita
menos inversión también a nivel de la
producción es menos costosa
y eso también facilitó el hecho de que
se crearán y se narrarán historias
[Música]
de dónde eres de mi título son papas o
campeón mundial es presidente tengo en
la familia de ellos y tener gata yo no
quiero hablar no quiero hablar de esto
habla de estos hermanos campeones en la
familia quien me hizo cuña en una
federación para entrar quien me quien
habló en un gimnasio para que me
acogieron con un felicidad y cariño y
nadie hermano nadie a historias muy
insólitas muy increíbles y pues que
también merecen ser narradas y eso pues
enriquece la cinematografía en general
de américa latina
este año el festival de biarritz
presenta una selección especial de
películas sobre el exilio de los
latinoamericanos en eeuu experiencia que
han vivido millones de latinos en busca
de una nueva vida con su lote de
encantos desilusiones y cambios nos lo
cuenta melissa barra
[Música]
más de 60 millones de latinos en eeuu
reivindican ser la primera minoría en
este país al mismo tiempo que el español
es la segunda lengua más hablada después
del inglés experiencias de exilio
inmigración e integración que se
reflejan en el cine y en las nueve
películas que componen la selección
latino xinyu es el que presenta este año
el festival de biarritz
[Música]
hacía mucho tiempo que queríamos hacer
una programación sobre los vínculos
entre estados unidos y américa latina y
claro con la política migratoria de
donald trump y con las elecciones
presidenciales en eeuu el 3 de noviembre
próximo
nos pareció muy de actualidad hacer esta
programación este año así que por eso
este focus latinos si lo desea
yo me voy a ir
[Música]
y lo hago por el niño césar y no es el
que más me necesita ahorita el problema
está de que o sea para el niño eres un
desconocido en la programación se puede
destacar como dos temáticas una que es
la situación bastante esquizofrénica de
los migrantes latinoamericanos que
siempre están viviendo en un país pero
pensando en otro y la otra temática es
al contrario gente que se fue hallada a
eeuu para reinventarse cosas que no
podían hacer en américa latina en su
país lo pueden hacer lo pueden realizar
de manera mucho más libre en eeuu
siempre uno puede aprovechar algo de la
situación
muy importante
[Música]
aquí cerramos a esta edición especial de
carrusel de las artes desde el balneario
de biarritz y los vamos a dejar con la
cumbia del grupo sopa loca grupo que
estuvo presente en esta edición número
29 del festival biarritz américa latina'
muchísimas gracias por su sintonía jaua
[Música]
ahora
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
como tal
[Aplausos]
[Música]